One of my favorite passages in Scripture is Exodus 6.
Why Exodus 6? Well, it's not because of Moses, believe it or
not, and it's not because that, you know, Moses is on the brink of the Israelites
leaving Egypt and this really cool escape plan that Moses is going to lead, you
know, the nation of Israel. No.
Believe it or not, here's why.
Because we discover something about God that we did not previously know from the
very beginning of Scripture all the way up to now.
In verse 1 of chapter 6, The Lord said to Moses, Now you will see
what I will do to Pharaoh. Because of my mighty hand, he will let them go.
Because of my mighty hand, he will drive them out of his country.
God also said to Moses, I am the Lord.
I appear to Abraham, to Isaac, and to Jacob as God Almighty.
But by my name, the Lord, I did not make myself known to them.
I also established my covenant with them to give them the land of Canaan where they
lived as aliens. Moreover, I have heard the groaning of the Israelites whom the
Egyptians are enslaving, and I have remembered my covenant.
I love this passage because this is where we start to see God in a different
light, more than just this idea of God Almighty.
So Abraham, Isaac, and Jacob sort of saw God as God Almighty.
And all that means is the God that's better than every other God, the creator God,
just this sort of person up here.
Now there's some relational stuff going on with those three, but not in the same way
that we see it with Moses he makes the covenant but here he remembers the covenant
and the covenant's becoming more of a reality than it was before this is where we
start to see the personal nature of God and that is incredibly important we
start talking about monotheism because we're not just talking about the fact that a
singular God exists. We're talking about something slightly more than that.
Now, we're talking about naturalism.
We talked about the dominant view of the West.
We talked about pantheism, the dominant view of the East.
We talked about sort of, you know, the conversions of the two and how they don't
work on the buffet. And we talked about all of those things.
Monotheism really is the view that God has made himself known, that God has made
himself known to us in a very personal and very very real way.
But so before we need to make a case for Christianity to be true, before we go any
further, right? We've talked about what truth is and logic and faith and
apologetics. And we've talked about worldviews and we've talked about naturalism.
We've talked about pantheism. Before we go any further, before we talk about the
resurrection and before we talk about Scripture and before we talk about how God has
made himself known, we need to be able to show that there is is a single,
personal, all-powerful creator. So I want to make something really clear here.
We're talking about monotheism as a worldview.
So within that worldview, you have other religions as well.
You have Judaism, you have Christianity, but you also have Islam.
Now when we're talking about the buffet of a bunch of worldviews, when we're talking
about monotheism, we're talking Listen, we're going to put the buffet aside and
we're going to order off a menu and get the actual dish that we know is the best
possible dish that satisfies us the most, gives us the proper nutrients.
In other words, the worldview that is most consistent, the worldview that is most
coherent, and the worldview that speaks to reality the best.
Right now we're going to talk about specifically next week and moving forward of why
Christianity within the framework of monotheism is true right
and the rest of them will go away but for this right now we're just talking about
monotheism in general and we're talking about the idea of a loving personal God
now when we talked about pantheism we talked about the idea of that that there needs
to be some kind of distinction, right?
So we're going to take that distinction and take it one step further and talk
specifically about the idea of a personal, caring God.
But I could take that even one step further.
If you go back to Exodus 6, you look at what God says.
He says, I am the Lord, I appeared to Abraham, Isaac, and Jacob as God Almighty.
I appeared to them in one way.
But by myself, by my name, the Lord, this is
again going back to the idea of Yahweh I am who I am the
name of God the utter holiness of God the other thanness of God
God takes who he is a step further in front of Moses and says I am
more than just God Almighty over everything else I am who I am.
Yahweh. And they kind of describe what that looks like, and we can add into our
focus the idea of a God who redeems.
A God who is not just out there creating things and leaving it alone.
We're talking about a God who is actively engaged in history,
redeeming, pursuing his own creation, creation that is made in his
image. He is chasing after us, even after we screwed it up.
He is chasing us down, drawing us back to him because of his
love for us. That's pretty profound.
That sets us up for what Jesus does, right?
That sets us up for belief in the Holy Spirit.
That sets us up for the belief in the Trinity.
That gives us a better understanding of who God is as we move into really what
this idea of monotheism actually looks like.
So, we've had you take your students, especially in small groups and working through
the Bible study in large group, sort of really get a feel for how
naturalism and how pantheism sort of has infiltrated and influenced our current
culture.
I want you to sort of back out of that for a second and sort of return to tables.
And I want you to explore with your students now how looking at the world through
the eyes of a monotheistic worldview, how that could actually influence
the culture. Because ultimately as Christians, we are called to get into our culture
and impact our culture for the gospel, right?
So what does that look like? So how then does your worldview change?
So even for your students who maybe don't see the world through a monotheistic
worldview just yet, encourage them to take a step back and ask them what would it
look like if I viewed the world that way?
What would it look like if I saw God as one God, more than one
God, as a personal God, more than just a personal God, as one who cares and is
actually pursuing me individually?
How would that change your students' lives?
How would that change their thoughts on morality?
How would that change their thoughts on justice?
How would that change their thoughts on love, on their relationships with their
friends and their family? How would it even change how they function at school?
How would their entire lives change if they thought that way, right?
So have them explore what that looks like and encourage them to sort of maybe try
it out and see what happens. And then as we continue to move forward will be
building the case that within the monotheistic framework
Christianity represents absolute truth.